[Music]
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
welcome to the bonus show we are
starting to see something that that is
quite interesting to me
um but not altogether surprising which
is that
there is blowback against these 10
republican members of the house or some
of these 10 republican house
of representatives members who voted in
favor of donald trump's impeachment
yesterday as we talked about on the
broadcast show
every democrat who voted voted for
impeachment and 10 republicans
left the democrat left the republicans
on this one issue and voted to impeach
along with the democrats and one of them
is liz cheney the congresswoman who also
is the daughter of former vice president
dick
cheney and very quickly conservative
uh i don't know what we would call them
the more extreme trumpist conservatives
are very angry with liz cheney
and there's a few different things going
on here
first of all is there something about
liz cheney that's different than the
others
i believe pat she's the only woman that
uh participated in this right
there's one more her other butler i have
the last herrera butler that's right
that's right
okay so she's one of only two women
and certainly more prominent than the
other woman so we could speculate
whether there's some kind of gender
aspect as to why republicans are
focusing on liz cheney rather than
anybody else i don't know the answer to
that um
but there's also claims about how she
should resign because of some kind of
dereliction of duty
which is so crazy to me pat because you
can disagree with the vote
but who can disagree that it is up to
the house to determine whether to
impeach i mean this is the
responsibility and duty of the house
as assigned constitutionally why would
someone have to resign because they
carried that duty out
right and liz cheney she is in
leadership she's the number three
republican in the house and they're
trying to push her out of leadership
after this and that's up for them to
decide
we've talked a lot about how these
republicans who have decided to impeach
trump like they're not all that
courageous
no they're doing the right thing here
but it seems like a no-brainer i mean
the president attacked congress and then
didn't do anything to stop the attack it
should just be an obvious vote to
impeach everyone in the house should
have voted to impeach yesterday
but of course most republicans don't
have a spine and they put their party
ahead of their country time and time
again
but you know i think these 10
republicans do deserve a little bit of
credit right because we want them to do
the right thing
but then when you look at the states
that they're from a lot of them are
blue states purple states like i see one
from new york
illinois michigan washington
liz cheney is the exception she's from a
very red state in wyoming but
it seems like even the 10 republicans
who voted for impeachment it was less
about principle and more about political
expediency because
they could just be coming from purple
districts right now as you point out
liz cheney from the very red state of
wyoming and um
she insists this is not a calculation of
any kind other than it's just her
conscience her consciences that she
should
and you know what i don't totally
disbelieve that i think it's actually
plausible that that is the case
um but the calls are for her to resign
some are calling
for her to resign altogether others are
saying she should resign her post on the
freedom caucus
and she says she's not going to go um
willingly and listen if they vote to
remove her ultimately they're voting to
remove her and she would have to do
she would have to abide by that but she
is not going to leave
and um i i think that the the real the
interesting thing for me here pat
is more about what are the next two
years like for the republican party
because there are going to be a lot of
different
factors pulling people in different
directions we've suspected for a long
time
that republicans in particular in the
senate and
many in the house never liked trump or
have been sick of him for a while and
are eager for him to go
this doesn't excuse their complicity
i've said like i said before
cowardice fear of reprisals or whatever
that doesn't excuse
the complicity you're still complicit
but you have the one factor which is a
lot of these republicans have probably
been sick of trump or never really were
with trump to begin with
you have publicly these new newer
right-wing media channels like oan and
newsmax which seem committed to
continuing the trumpian q anon sort of
line for the next two years
you also have the reality that based on
this recent polling
most republican voters are still with
trump as far as they're concerned trump
is still the leader
and they still look to trump and trump
if he wants to continue having influence
over the party
he will be able to uh in in all
likelihood so i i'm genuinely curious
about what the right wing movement is
going to look like over the next two
years
yeah we'll have to wait and see i mean
if you just kind of follow the normal
pendulum of politics it would suggest
that republicans will pick up seats
in 2022 and the midterms come around
because uh usually the incumbent
president has a bad first midterm
so that could possibly happen but i
think a lot may have to do with what
takes place
in the senate trial because if the
senators vote to convict trump and he's
banned from ever serving in federal
office again
uh that could backfire tremendously on
republicans because maybe their base
will be just
so upset about that that they still
supports trump and they may not turn out
for republicans going forward
but it could also be bad for republicans
if they decide not to convict not to ban
trump from federal office going forward
because in that case i think trump could
come back in 2024
but there will be a big push within the
establishment ranks of the republican
party
to try to box him out so you could have
a situation where you have the
democratic candidate in 2024
be it biden or kamala or whoever going
against an establishment republican
and trump and then the republicans would
have no chance of winning at that point
so
they could be screwed either way we
could see a big transition happening
over the next two years it's so hard to
predict the future but i don't think the
republicans are set up very well right
now
i don't know that i even for a second by
the idea that trump at close to 80 years
old is going to do another run for
whatever reason i'm finding it
implausible regardless of whether he's
allowed to or not
but he's 74 now he would be 78 in 2024
and that's the same age that biden is
now so i don't think it's entirely out
of the question
and i think that trump even though he
has a
bad diet and like you wouldn't think
that he'd be someone who would live to
be a hundred or whatever for whatever
reason he just strikes me as someone
who's going to live
a very long time i don't know why what
is true is that in the united states
wealthier people tend to live longer
because there are such disparities in
health care and so a guy who
by by all reasonable accounts is
probably qualifies as obese and needs an
unhealthy diet and doesn't doesn't
exercise
you're not wrong that it's possible for
whatever reason i just don't see trump
having the energy or the interest four
years from now to do this again but i
could be wrong we don't know we really
just don't
do you want to see him gone for good
because a part of me wants him to stay
around stay relevant because i think
he's going to continue to have a bad
influence
on the republican party and lead to
democrats winning going forward but yeah
that could ultimately backfire i mean
there were people in the 2016
race who thought that it would be good
to have trump to run against because
then we could defeat him so easily and
of course that backfired
so uh you know he'll do what he's going
to do republicans are going to do what
they're going to do and
all we can do is try to oppose them
that's all we can really do part of me
wants to have him stick around so that
he drags the republican party down
and then to see him lose in 2024 even
even lose the primary would be
fascinating although every indication is
if he wants it he gets it in 2024.
if you're a republican though and you
saw trump won
the primary in 2016 so
if you wanted to if you ran in 2016 you
you lost good
2020 there was no there was no primary
because the sitting president
gets to essentially say there's no
primary if i want it
and then if in 2024 donald trump decides
to run if the republican party decides
to let him have it or if it simply is
difficult to really challenge him for it
you basically will have 14 years from
2012 to 2028
between non-trump republican primaries
which is a really long time for a party
to just be dealing with trump as the
nominee
yeah and the people who are waiting
patiently to be the next nominee like
ted cruz
and they're not going to be so happy
with that before
the georgia senate races and before the
insurrection at the capitol
i thought that if trump runs in 2024
he's got the republican nomination
hands down because he has so much
control over the party now things have
changed a little bit where they may
think he's toxic because he lost them
the georgia senate seats and also what
took place
the other day so it could be a little
bit different now
we'll we'll just wait and see and the
first question is i mean listen
january 21st to 28th will be a week
during which we will see do we hear
anything from trump or does he already
start to kind of evaporate into the
ether we'll see and we'll follow it
there has been a really wild situation
happening within the house of
representatives where after the
sea the riotous insurrectionist siege
last week there has been a decision made
to have members of congress walk through
metal detectors
after uh on their way into the house
chamber
and members of both parties have
expressed some frustration at the lines
that have formed at the entrance to the
house floor
and many republicans are saying that
this is an invasive measure
but at the same time we started to hear
from people like
congress woman lauren beaubert who's out
of her mind
congresswoman marjorie taylor green
who's completely cuckoo for cocoa puffs
and congressman uh madison cawthorne who
has said on the charlie kirk show
that he has multiple firearms with him
on the floor of the house about how
they don't like this and they're even
saying nancy pelosi is trying to
disarm us how insane is the fact that
this conversation is even happening
but it should be happening especially
because we're still investigating
whether or not
the capital insurrection was an inside
job in part and whether there were
congress people who aided some of the
rioters right because we heard reports
about how there were panic buttons taken
away from the house
and specific locations within the house
were somehow known to these rioters even
though it's the type of thing that
you wouldn't really know unless you were
on the inside uh so
i think at the very least while all
that's being investigated while they're
taking a look at some of these
republican
lawmakers who could have been complicit
in the attack last week
you have to have metal detectors because
you can't trust members of congress how
crazy
is that that that's where we are right
now trust fellow members of congress
that they're not going to try to kill
people or anything else
even more broadly not just in the
aftermath of a riotous insurrection
why would members of the house bring
guns anyway like
it just doesn't make any sense anyway
well i think they would argue now
that they need to have their guns in
case the police can't be there to aid
them
given what happened last week the police
got taken over and that was the last
line of defense that they had their gun
on them
but you know as we know if just because
you have a gun on you that doesn't mean
it's going to protect you it can be
turned against you you could be killing
the wrong people
and a bunch of other bad things can
happen just because you have the gun on
it but what does it say about the united
states
if the house floor is so dangerous that
members need to be armed
like that that what country you know
look at the countries where that's the
case
well it that's crazy it's absolutely
crazy um
and also it seems like the people who
are armed are the actual threats like
they're not protecting against threats
they're the q a they are the
rights they're the craziest members of
congress they're the people who are
probably most likely to perpetrate some
sort of attack because
that's where their ideology is but it's
also that
that ideology is reflexive of uh of um
the districts that they represent like
the people who are voting for these
lawmakers are crazy themselves too
yeah and they have crazy lawmakers
packing them and you know that's sort of
like what
we're dealing with right now this is the
vicious cycle and circle that we're
going to be seeing
uh the impact of in these in these next
two years
some very interesting news out of
michigan former michigan governor rick
snyder has been charged with willful
neglect of duty after an investigation
into the decisions he made that led to
the flint michigan
water crisis remember the lead
contamination of water in flint michigan
still has not been resolved it led to a
regional outbreak of legionnaires
disease
and uh the charges which uh rick snyder
has has been
charged with are misdemeanors and
they're punishable by up to a year in
jail and a thousand dollar fine
and th this is so there's two two uh
approaches to this one this is
groundbreaking and unprecedented no
governor or former governor in
michigan's history
has ever been charged with crimes
related to their activities while
in office at the same time
um we are not i don't think pat going to
see any jail time i know that it's up to
a year and a thousand dollar fine he's
going to have top-notch attorneys i
would be shocked if he does any jail
time but for me the real concern is less
about jail time although
certainly our elected officials should
be held accountable they still haven't
dealt with the water problem in flint
michigan that's the issue
yeah i think he's going to be charged
really with the dear election of duty
knowing that there was a problem with
the water for 18 months it's not just
the fact that he
moved to get the water and flint from
the
river there uh he also just did nothing
about it
during the time when we knew that this
was causing problems for
citizens and there should be
consequences i don't think he's going to
serve jail time of course he'll probably
just have to pay that fine and that'll
be
it um but you know there's also the
argument that this doesn't go nearly as
far enough because
you're harming young people you're
harming future generations with lead in
the water
and if the only consequence for such a
thing is a thousand dollar fine
then is that really even a consequence
at all well
this gets to the bigger debate that
exists as to
the standard for charging elected
officials
criminally in general and you know when
you talk about
decisions presidents make that lead to
deaths there are these exceptions where
like if the context is geopolitical
conflict then you're making decisions
about the military
even if your decision is essentially
we're sending troops and they go and
they kill ten thousand people somewhere
else
you're not criminally liable for that
and then you get questions of war crimes
that you you know
there's this immunity that is implicit
or assumed
when elected officials are making
certain types of decisions particularly
at the very top level
and that gets to a debate about
something like this if rick snyder as
governor
knows about an issue and does nothing
about it and it leads to legionnaires
outbreaks and it leads to
all these long-term health problems and
so on and so forth
what should his criminal liability be i
think that elected officials should not
be exempt from criminal liability
but i think that the debate as to how it
should be approached is actually a
difficult debate
yeah it's interesting because when you
talk about something like war crimes
the people in charge can at least use
the defense of oh i was protecting
american citizens right we used drone
strikes so we didn't have to send in our
soldiers
right we can protect them in that way
they can usually come up with some sort
of excuse
the only excuse here really is that he
wanted to protect business interests and
allow them to keep making
more money yeah while people suffered
and had to deal with these
long-lasting diseases because of his
malpractice or insisting he didn't
really know although that ship has
sailed
yeah so i mean it's it's even comparing
it to war crimes like
in some in some sense like this could
even be worse than some of the things
that we've seen in the middle east or
you know around the world because like
this happened in his own state and he
did nothing about it it happened to his
own citizens and he did nothing about it
i saw some images this morning from his
i guess it was his arraignment and you
know it was all done via zoom
people had masks and some okay it's the
a lot of this stuff and this goes back
to our conversation yesterday about the
capital rioters
a lot of these things are going to move
very slowly because of the virus and
that's just going to
we're just going to have to wait a long
time to see the resolution for a lot of
these things
yeah it's kind of a bummer in a sense
because we want to move on especially
given the the riot stuff we have a new
president coming in
like if i was an incoming president i
probably wouldn't want to have to deal
with
the wrongdoings of the former president
i would just want to move on in passing
my agenda and making that 100 percent
the focus but
biden's not going to be able to do that
but you know we still have to
go through this process though because
we can't let people get away with stuff
like this there has to be consequences
there has there have to be there no no
doubt about it so we will be following
it
we will have a new show and a new bonus
show tomorrow reminder reminder reminder
we are off for martin luther king day on
monday this is one where you know in the
past pat
we've not taken it off sometimes and we
will get emails saying
how dare you do a show on martin luther
king day it is disrespectful to martin
luther king day
um and listen if people are saying no
show then we will
we will not do a show but in all
seriousness uh
because of just the lack of of uh of
anything really happening due to the
virus and everything else
we are taking advantage of it we expect
that inauguration week is going to be
pretty crazy so there will be no show
monday
in observance of martin luther king jr
day and then we will be here
tuesday wednesday inauguration day live
stream so it'll be a busy week
regardless
yeah i think columbus day slash
indigenous people's day is the other
holiday where we sometimes take it off
we sometimes work it yeah and people get
angry either way either way happens
about twice a year and yeah we're just
used to it at this point
the um the other one is um is it
president's day in february
where some people just say it's too
minor a holiday to take off
right yeah like there are the six major
federal holidays
that you have to take off july labor day
uh memorial day memorial day
christmas even though that's more
controversial and uh i don't know rick
perry moment i can't remember
i think it's massachusetts and maine and
maine used to be part of massachusetts
right doesn't even count very good well
a lesson on
holidays but the whole point of this is
we're going to be off on monday but
we'll still see everybody tomorrow
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com